what's more important to Story the hero
or the villain I think the villain is
usually more colorful
the hero can be very Bland
without the villain you don't have a
hero you got to give the hero something
to do
that he can Triumph them triumph over at
the end
you don't want the villain to be I mean
people say that I would like to see the
villain win for a change but they don't
it wouldn't it would leave them
unfulfilled unsatisfied missing
something
and um
a kill a hero can be pretty
he can be pretty boring actually
but if you give them heroic things to do
that sort of livens them up but the
villain can be outrageous in your
flamboyant uh
well excuse me way over the top
and a hero can't really do then unless
you're doing a satire or a Lampoon or
something
how does the villain reflect the hero
well some some characters like
Batman and the Joker a lot of people
point it they're really kind of
reflections of each other one is both
they're both obsessive they're both go
to no ends but there are not yin and
yang
Frankenstein's monster and Victor
Frankenstein has created is looked at
the same way kind of like
two personifications Jekyll and Hyde
where juggling height is all in the same
person I think that's a true to a lot of
Heroes that they are simply
in some ways finding themselves
would you argue that the antagonist
should be twice as strong as the hero
it's always best to make the
the antagonist the villain the bad guy
who have more advantages than the hero
either they're physically stronger
in the case of Superman
they you know they were there what we're
going to do we can do anything you know
nothing has happened that's when they
came up with the idea for Kryptonite and
the old Superman radio show and then Lex
Luthor was this Evil Genius so he made
up in brains with Superman made up in
physical attributes yeah because you
don't want to have a hero that can just
punch the guy and that's the end of it
and you got to give him
uh adversaries that either smarter or
more powerful than he or she happens to
be give them challenges that are even
like a Greek mythology and everything
the when the heroes will go on these
Odysseys and things
they would have to be up against things
that were greater than they were other
things otherwise they're not really so
much as the hero they're more of a just
of a bully you know and there's a big
difference
how would you teach me to write an
antagonist
well I
I think I learned how to write Heroes
and the antagonists just by
having a huge background of reading a
lot
seeing a lot of movies seeing a lot of
television shows listening to our radio
shows reading mythology and uh I'm a big
big fan of um Joseph Campbell
you know he there was a series years ago
on PBS
that uh
who was it Bill Bill Moyer yeah Bill
Moyer moderated
that was just brilliant
and um
you know things about symbolism and
things I wrote a book on symbolism years
ago uh as an assignment where I was
working for a comic book company and
they said we want you to put as many of
these values in as possible and um
little things like
if you have the hero on in a ship and
it's a voyage going to this mysterious
land
you should have him if you can have him
traveling from
east to west and said I mean west to
east instead of east to west because
what that sets up in your mind
of the reader or if you're watching it
on the screen
is
if you're going east to west it's
contrary
to the way you normally read a book
your eyes go unless you're in from some
exotic country or something your eyes go
from left to right and going against a
grain sort of unconsciously
puts in your in your your mind the idea
of conflict coming up and I try to do
that as much as I can
um
I was making a this werewolf movie
and my producer couldn't understand why
I wanted the evil villainous
who was like the queen of the werewolves
to have dark hair and the innocent
virginal well not so version but the
innocent um good girl who gets sucked
into her
cult or her pack be blonde I said it's
it's just like in the old Flash Gordon
movie cereal when they had Dale Arden
his Flash's girlfriend with blonde hair
and the evil queen Aura with black hair
and they which it was a complete switch
from the comic strip it was opposite in
the comic strip and I said that's going
to make people accept her more as the
villain it's like in western movies with
the with the bad guy convoys with the
black hats and the hero with the white
hats the same thing
do you spend more time writing the hero
or the villain well when I'm writing a
story
I think it all just comes out in the
wash and I just in a linear way go
through the story
and if the villain has more pages or
screen time that's the way the the plot
worked out I don't think I know
self-consciously
think about it I have more fun with the
villains of course I get you get to say
a lot more outrageous things and do a
lot more outrageous things and a lot of
times the hero is doing things
defensively because it's the the villain
who's initiating the Mayhem or creating
the threat you know so the heroes
villains are always more fun
why is evil important in storytelling
well without evil
and again if you wanna
distill that a little bit just say
negativity
um
is he as important in stories because
without it you don't your story doesn't
really work
unless you're writing some just some
goodie tutu and that's going to be on uh
one of the cable networks you know that
doesn't have any conflict in it uh you
gotta have
good versus evil I mean that goes back
to morale morality plays
Greek mythology it's a it's just
it's just drama it's what drama is all
about good versus evil or at least
conflict if it's a story about us
school teacher or school principal
and it's a school base he's got to have
some kind of a opposition whether it's
the school is going to be closed down
and you've got to raise money some kind
of a challenge something something to do
to be become heroic
what are your favorite hero versus
villain battles well you mean like in
movies and things yeah or in a comic
book
one uh one of my favorite movie
battles of hero against villain
I don't think villainy
has been ever has been ever I mean sure
you can have movies of Hitler doing
horrible things but I'm turning just
personality villainy and personality
heroics
was the climactic sword fight between
Errol Flynn his Robin Hood and basil
Rathbone as uh sir guy of Ginsburg or
whatever that was that five was just so
and it wasn't that involved it was a
sword fighting up and down these stairs
and they're down these days I forget
which it was and also this fight between
Zorro
as played by Tyrone Power and basil
Rathbone again in the mark of Zorro
those are
perfect fights they end with the hero
winning they don't leave up in the air
uh like
some of the science fiction movies now
the hero they just is legally open-ended
and to me that's not the way the heroes
Village be they um
there's a scene in the original or that
Boris Carlo Frankenstein too
where the monster and
his creator confront each other out in
the mountains and they just stare at
each other and that moment even though
nothing is happening in it you just know
there's the conflict between the well if
you want to call the
the Frankenstein Henry Frankenstein a
heroic figure at least he's trying to
destroy the monster he created you know
and but that looked at the two of them
exchanges is wonderful
do most viewers or readers identify with
the villain or the hero
I don't know who I identify with I like
to say identify with the hero
and um
I I I like in the in the novel
Frankenstein though
where everybody identified
if I was with the monster because you're
going through this awkward period of
their teenage years and all this then
the misunderstood and everything I was
asked by the BBC ones I was doing a an
interview for them on Frankenstein
and they asked me uh
who I you know about identifying with
the monster and I thought about I said
wait a minute
I never identified with the monster I
identified with Victor who created the
monster even though he's a vile
character in the book
the reason being he actually did some
things he actually made some things I
mean what he created got out of hands
but he did it and I was ever since I was
a kid I liked I like to make things I
like to see things
being from start to finish being created
that's really I love to tell stories I
love to make you know with crafts and
things and I was always doing that sort
of thing so I think I in that one case
more people consider
the months are put upon and all this I
mean and Victor Frankenstein being the
actual villain in that story I guess I
identified with the villain in that
story